by the way i love your background i'm
keep talking to people with boring
backgrounds and yours is fantastic
yeah i refuse to be deemed boring no
this is a kind of a moroccan
kind of backdrop situation yeah it's
it's it's very cool i want to sort of
get you a hookah pipe or something it's
very exotic i love it uh i don't know if
i don't know if they told you i'm in a
uh
a theater here in los angeles and it
occurred to me
uh that you have spent the good part of
your life you've cut your teeth in the
theater of obviously you've
made a big splash in films but um
what is it about the theater cause i'm
i'm not familiar
with the theater world the legitimate
theater world i worked as a stripper for
a while
um and i earned no money i ended up
owing money
i'm trying to get these images out of my
head man sorry
i know i apologize let's just say it
didn't go well for anybody
but what is it uh is there anything
in all the years that you did theater uh
was there anything that you could just
never get used to
in the theater anything that still
strikes you as odd or weird oh god
the the weirdest thing and the thing i
am still
crafting trying to learn i don't know
that i'll ever
conquer it is the quintessential
bow so i don't know if you've ever
if you've ever been called on to to to
bow after having given some kind of
performance but when i was at the royal
shakespeare company i was there
with actors like francis de la torre and
alan bates and these were titans of
theater
uh 20 years ago when i was sort of
cutting my teeth and
they had this knack of doing this bow
regardless by the way of how bad the
performance had been
of it was this combination of
tiredness um uh false humility
and grandeur in the bowel um i'm
actually gonna demonstrate because
there's there's there's
there's i don't know if i can even do it
with this backdrop but you know
you can give it a shot that's okay i'm
gonna move my chair
okay so you you you i'm gonna tilt this
up so you can
can we say this is the quintessential
royal shakespeare bow
[Laughter]
i love the shock at getting paused
because i live in a world and i see this
all the time in america
where there's an applause sign right and
someone who does a show
night in and night out walks out and is
like
there's a goddamn button there's a
button and you hear this
every night
[Music]
and you're right it combines humility
with incredible arrogance
oh absolutely absolutely and i've not
been able to find the intersection of
both
where like i say even if you've given a
bad performance the audience just feels
the need to go
oh yeah oh yeah
it's like you're really just applauding
the bow when you think about it
and they go home thinking that they
watched a great show it's a great skill